well time now to get the view from
labour because the party of course keen
to focus on the cost of living crisis
and has put forward its own plans on
energy prices we can talk now to
labour's nick thomas uh simmons who is
the shadow international trade secretary
thank you very much for being with us
this morning
it looks like liz trust is going to be
the next prime minister would she be an
improvement on the last one
well first of all very good to join you
this morning
sophie
whether she will be an improvement
on boris johnson who frankly
trashed the office of prime minister
only time in the end will tell
what i've seen over the summer frankly
are two conservative leadership
candidates living in some sort of
parallel reality i think of the
constituents who are emailing me who are
speaking to me whenever i'm out and
about who are so fearful about the
pressures on family budgets this winter
and yet the conservative party has spent
well over two months talking to itself
and left in place a zombie government
that frankly has been doing nothing over
the summer whilst people are so
incredibly worried
uh it certainly does feel like people
are concerned about the cost of living
crisis going forward um she has said of
course uh that she wants to have
immediate action on energy bills to try
and you know help families and also
businesses and then tax cuts you know
some people listening to that might be
thinking that sounds pretty good
well we'll have to just see what
uh is actually brought forward next week
to be able to judge that i mean the
debate over the summer has not
particularly
shown a focus on what people are facing
or indeed an understanding of the scale
of the crisis but what we are saying
very clearly is freeze energy bills
freeze that price cap so people are not
paying a penny more and take that worry
away from people and also i listened
with interest sophie to your last
interview we also need to be putting in
place
support for businesses and what labor is
saying is we would be putting in place a
contingency fund of a billion pounds for
energy intensive businesses in addition
to that we would be raising the
threshold at which business rates are
paid
before then actually reforming business
rates and we'd be raising that money
from an increase in the digital services
tax we've got to be helping households
we've got to be helping businesses as
well
um i'm also interested to uh know
your take on whether or not there might
be an early election there has been a
bit of speculation is labor on an
election footing
we are absolutely on an election footing
and i want to see this government swept
away as soon as possible these are
continuity candidates and part of the
conservative debate over the summer has
been about all the problems that have
been caused by 12 years of conservative
rule to sweep this government away we
need to have that general election and
we in labor want to see that general
election happen as soon as we possibly
can so we can get on with the job of
rebuilding our country's economy and
standing beside people in this acute
cost of living crisis that looks like
it's only going to get worse in the
months ahead
we spoke to lord lister also earlier on
the program of course someone who's been
very close to boris johnson for a long
time and he said
that he wouldn't rule out a return
to frontline politics for boris johnson
if the ball came loose at the back of
the scrum he wouldn't rule anything out
do you think that boris johnson
could come back
it really does show the depths to which
the conservative party has sunk and the
fact they are so
tired after 12 years in office that
they've just ousted
a
leader after his flagrant disregard for
kovid rules after he showed time and
again it was one rule for him and
another rule for the rest of the
population it really does show now the
conservative party has completely lost
its way if they they are saying credibly
that they want to get rid of one leader
then try to have a leadership contest
with others then try and bring the other
leader back the only way we're ever
going to get a fresh start is to sweep
the conservatives away completely
okay thank you very much indeed nick
thomas simmons there for the labour
party